le hasard fait bien les choses allaient
chéri la halle et via la batala plus tu
n'as plus à choisir
tu te laisses guide et t'inquiète pas
encore c'était moi qui c'est raoul
bah oui bétail on sait que c'est moi qui
les ont les cheveux du smac
ah oui mais du coup c'est roland
scheubel roulage de pelles et de la bam
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on démarre donc avec le groupe à
matthieu delormeau et daniel on va voir
le score que vous allez faire tous les
deux une attention moi c'est l'essai du
bras droit
j'ai jamais fait ses gammes chavez n'a
jamais tapé dans son rôle de coach et
par va la laisser monter sa ferme et a
fait dans une boule de glace
alors il m'a dit papa à l'intérieur
parce qu'on risque de se casser le dos
et et faire la rotation des pôles
d'accord avec ça on va essayer non
c'était pas d'y aller avec 14,4 du
sommaire on va voir qui va faire le plus
dans les bidons c'est palerme qui
combine 114 ont le brevet vous gardez
vos trucs le groupe bel et bien pas
remontés dont vous êtes nuls à 214 c'est
du latin sujet j'ai pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
247 conduire à des ragots avec
jean-michel vazimba paraît il est
largement devant rama ignoble 247,6 on
nous fait 646 ses 146 846 malaisie le
groupe c à bord l'instant c'est jean
michel et gérald dahan n'y croit
[Applaudissements]
pas possible de chiffrer comme il se
remet ça mais c'est pas trop si la
parfaite lui 100 cède non vous êtes
éliminés c'est toujours jean michel
[Applaudissements]
chacun groupe et dernier vous allez
c'est pas maintenant il reste le juge et
des deux fils était allé à tension a été
tout de suite donc ne vous blessez pas
attention à respecter aussi les gardes
et à 896 aux régions pour tomber à 1 848
merci pas mal pas mal et ne croit tubes
en effet géré ip que toi sinon ça
suffira pas c'est toujours jean michel
et bien à lui
kelly et maxime nommé battre à 2 à 2 846
irradiée n'a fêté n'ont pas voulu qu'il
faut préférer qui commence à les battre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez allez 200 aliments non
investissant les six ans
je demande juste un petit but face au
chili nous a fait tous pensé à cette
meuf la relève et regarder cette meuf la
rive et bien comme quoi ça arrive
regardez il est très bon allez attention
ainsi quels moyens d'y aller on enlève
sa maxime c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
j'ai perdu j'ai perdu tout sauf
qu'attention géraldine et jean michel
vous allez être en finale peut-être pour
gagner un magnifique connaître venez la
foule que je vous propose
ok donc vous êtes très fort c'est que
vous allez combattre contre arsène et
moi quoi vous additionnez vous devriez
[Musique]
en faire tuer moi je suis dans cette
question fait les payements directs
alors vous voulez connemara carsen vous
démarrez vous êtes tous des héros te
plaise pas à t'inquiéter pas le ps pas
parce que on était champion du monde
vient n'a pas beaucoup la machine est
beau c'est beau c'est beau c'est pas
tout à fait mis sur quarante caméras pas
s'évanouir à 5145
[Applaudissements]
attention vous devez battre 845 en 146
baptisé non parce que je veux pas que tu
te sens bien mais je l'essayé fut
fabuleux livre examine ses comptes m
voilà attention non mais tous un peu
plus près j'ai l'impression que l'on
vient parce que ça me donne de moi mais
c'est sûr qu'on n'est pas trop loin
je vais voir je sais pas bâti match
aller
elle est maintenue on y va ce qu'ont
bien j'ai envie nos attractions 45 ils
allaient jean mignault sens magny ce
qu'on peut me faire le calcul en régie
sioux p300 750 mille cent quarante cinq
mois 240 687 ou régis ccsa site si vous
avez une calculette
merci attention aujourd'hui je vais te
dire exactement combien tu dois faire
pour gagner vous tu dois faire 558
est-ce que tu prends le joker et tu vois
je peux le faire
non non je reste solidaire avec wifi et
bien là c'est que ça soit 58,6 éviter
aux gens me est passé une grosse
confiance en toi tu vas me le taper
suisse genève attend et je vous jure
qu'il ya un très très beau cadeau à
gagner juste il faudrait me donner dans
l'oreillette
merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention c'est parti c'est bon je me
donnerai des terres peu loin frérot
dépend largement mélange donne tout en
janvier donne tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean-michel mais vous gagnez le nouveau
show redemption
voilà si on perd par micromania c'est
pour nous et on n'a pas de super g
messieurs il rejoint des consoles c'est
pourri sa part ça aussi ça c'est le
ramadhan des cvo vous ou bien sûr y voir
et idées pour on va se retrouver dans un
instant avec slimane ebit à jour et
qu'on applaudisse très très fort notre
[Applaudissements]
travail dans la botte
le shérif et à l hôtel jamais et c'est
un des plus grands champions du moment
tout plat tous sports confondus
donc merci nous aura fait plaisir d'être
à marseille
[Applaudissements]